The lower estimate, which comes from our red graph here, is 5.1 billion people.
And our upper estimate, which comes from this blue curve, is 36.1 billion.
There's such a huge difference between these two estimates, that I think if we
think about all the different factors that affect world population, we can see
why. There's so many things that influence the number of people in the world.
For example, we've seen an increase in world population due to decrease in
death rates, as people live longer because of better health care. In the
future, we have no idea what's going to happen. Maybe a pandemic will wipe
everyone out. Or maybe we'll have food shortages due to climate change. Or
perhaps advances in science mean an abundance of food and longer average
lifetimes. Who knows? If you're interested in this, and I personally think it's
a pretty fascinating topic, go to the forums and talk about this with your
fellow classmates. I think what this illustrates is that even though we can
make models, making a long term predictions, especially based on just
equations, can be pretty difficult. It's still, however, worth discussing.